hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
september 28th 2020 what's going on how
are you how's it going oh billy tired
voice
i did ten shows this week two tuesday
two wednesday
two thursday two friday tuesday
say and i got today off
sunday recording this thing at
uh during halftime well third quarter
just started
seattle versus dallas you already know
this game's [ __ ] over i knew this
game was over in the end of the second
quarter and now they just [ __ ] took
the ball away from the dallas cowboys
russell wilson arguably the best
quarterback in the league but he's you
know
undersized and he plays all the way up
there in seattle
so he doesn't get any love you know all
they care about
seattle is grunge music and [ __ ]
those guys throwing the fish you know
that's all that's what the global media
i mean well the national media cares
about seattle
you know you got to give it up to pete
carroll though man for as cloudy as it
is up there man that guy
somehow keeps that copper tone tan going
he's he's gonna be 70 [ __ ] years old
he has that dick clark gene he looks
great touchdown
seattle there you go
there you go i've been watching this
game i missed the pats game because i
was traveling
from connecticut drove down south so i
missed the whole [ __ ] game
um which sucks but i will tell you this
man i've been watching this
i watched the end of uh the bears come
back
against uh atlanta and uh in what world
is a super bowl winning quarterback a
backup
[ __ ] quarterback to mitch tabrizky
i'm not [ __ ] on him but i'm just
saying
you got nick foles sitting there and the
guy beat belichick and brady in a super
bowl
you know what are we doing here
he went down to jacksonville i know he
got hurt but what the [ __ ]
this guy's a winner man so he went in
there
and scored [ __ ] three touchdowns
unanswered
and kept the chicago bears undefeated
shout out to atlanta falcons fans i mean
how many [ __ ] leads
the it's becoming their identity down
there they got to somehow turn it around
you know no one likes to see that type
of [ __ ] happen i always say i enjoyed it
when it happened
when the patriots are playing them but
in general you know you got to feel for
those fans
no wonder they're pumping in [ __ ]
crowd noises down there
but anyways getting to what i really
wanted to talk about here
is how many [ __ ] times
is a wide receiver a running back a kick
returner or whatever
gonna think they have a touchdown and
not secure the football
only to have it punched out of their
[ __ ] hands
into the back of the end zone it
happened again
there's entire youtube videos
about people celebrating too soon
you would think with the shame that's
out there trying
not to get added to that video you would
think this guy in seattle wouldn't that
was it number 14 wouldn't do that [ __ ]
i shouldn't say the guy's number because
i don't remember who it was i don't get
[ __ ]
i want to make sure i get the right guy
i want to be on the right side of
history on this one
um i mean you look at nba players
they've seen enough [ __ ] on instagram of
what happens when you get dunked on now
anytime anybody goes up to dunk
everybody runs out of the [ __ ]
painted area
you know but for some reason these
goddamn football players i don't know
what it is
they start slowing down they drop the
ball they hold it out
they're looking for them you know
they're watching their highlight live on
the [ __ ] giant
replay screen whatever the [ __ ] you call
it the flat screen tv that they got it
radio shack or whatever
um how many [ __ ] times
i wonder if quarterbacks talk about that
i bet they all have that story
you know i was going to win this [ __ ]
game and i i
threw a 50-yard bomb caught this guy in
stride
oh great you win the game now the
[ __ ] idiot stuck the ball out
and started doing the [ __ ] macarena
or whatever on the three-yard line
and then the dude who he burned just
kept running and slapped it out of his
[ __ ] hand
you know like i hate when that happens
i hate when that happens jesus christ
the [ __ ] are people thinking russell
wilson man
i didn't realize you know he's some of
those guys you just take for granted
how well he throws the deep ball last
last week when he beat my patriots they
said
uh he throws the best deep ball in the
league he
compared it to you know dropping it down
the bucket or some [ __ ] like that i'm
watching this cowboys game and he's just
he doesn't miss the [ __ ] guy does not
miss it's amazing
i think you know because he lives up
there and he's also you know he's only
like six feet six feet one
six foot one they don't just they don't
look like a quarterback
[ __ ] it let's try to gas up uh
this other guy over here so we got a
football
qb controversy brewing in chicago
mitchell trebitsky taken out of the game
i believe
and they bring in nick foles what the
[ __ ] were they thinking
did wasn't he the [ __ ] mvp i'm gonna
look this [ __ ] up now
i can look nick foles super bowl
mvp there it is
after carson was injured late in the
regular season i remember that that
happened against the rams full i believe
foles led the eagles to the franchise
first third super bowl appearance they
defeated new england patriots in super
bowl 52 for their first super bowl title
with foals being named the games mvp
just started in defense of this let's
just look up a list of super bowl mvps
super bowl mvp
history let's see if there's any bums in
there
all right what are we doing here super
bowl mvps
come on bart starr hall of famer
bart starr hall of famer super bowl
three i'm going right here joe namath
hall of famer
lynn dawson hall of famer chuck howley
hall of famer roger staubach
hall of famer jake scott not a hall of
famer i don't believe he might be
larry zonka hall of famer franco harris
hall of famer lin swan
swan hall of famer fred vlitnikov harvey
martin terry bradshaw
terry bradshaw jim plunkett joe montana
john riggins marcus allen joe montana
richard dent
phil sims doug williams jerry rice
joe montana listen to these [ __ ]
names and nick foles can walk up to all
of these guys
and be like yeah i did that too
joe montana otis anderson mark rippian
mark griffian ah yeah i don't know otis
anderson was a great player he just
played with the [ __ ] cardinals so
nobody knew it troy aikman emmett smith
steve young larry brown
desmond howard tyrell
davis john elway kurt warner
ray uncle ray ray lewis tom brady
dexter jackson all right there's a few
in here where you're like well
who dexter jackson this is where i
really was doing a lot of stand up so i
don't want to disrespect anybody
he had two first half interceptions
all right larry brown had two
interceptions for the cowboys
super bowl 30. um
heinz ward peyton manning eli manning
first two brothers ever to do it san
antonio holmes
drew brees aaron rodgers eli
manning two-time super bowl mvp
joe flacco malcolm
he had smith interception for a
touchdown a fumble recovery and 10
tackles well there you go he [ __ ]
earned that tom brady
von miller tom brady
three-time super bowl mvp nick foles
julian edelman patrick mahomes
okay i don't know but you guys i was
pretty impressed with that list
i think i'd be starting that guy um
anyway hey pats fans are you guys
uh you getting concerned about these
buffalo bills
the [ __ ] is going on out there after
years of ineptitude
let's look up this josh allen guy see
what the [ __ ] he did today
i swear to god i'm going to start
getting into fantasy football because
this is the only way i can keep up on
the stats
you go to that goddamn cbs sports they
say they're going to have the [ __ ]
stats
stats are nowhere to be found or at
least i can't find them
today he had 363
and a half yards what the [ __ ] does that
mean how do you have 363 and a half
yards
okay at 727 yards in the first two weeks
what the [ __ ] did he do this week
please can't they just can't these
[ __ ] nerds just post this [ __ ]
what is stopping them
all right i give up i give i don't know
why this is so [ __ ] difficult
you know but you know what it is because
i want it i want it like literally 10
minutes after the [ __ ] game ended
maybe that's what it is i have no idea
all right anyway i want to thank
everybody who came out to my shows this
week
10 glorious shows and i went from a
rusty comic
to i got a legit ovation
i felt after my second show last night
where i was just
i was riffing i was doing my act i was
[ __ ]
you know messing with people driving by
in cars
you know i was doing this farm and this
guy kept driving by bb
bbb as he went by thinking he was
[ __ ] up the show he was helping me
out so shout out to him
i got to give a shout out to pig candy
this is the stuff you didn't know that
you need and you look
you didn't know that you needed in your
life
um pig candy recipes
uh it's like pigcandy.com or something
like that they
just made this amazing i can't even it's
like
sweet and savory [ __ ] bacon it was
insane
um but uh we were in i don't know where
that we were in morris connecticut
which had the best setup since i've been
doing parking lots
um it just was like
everybody was clearly separated they
marked a box where you had to sit
and um and even one show these [ __ ]
idiots weren't sitting in the box it's
hilarious it's like literally i was
joking i was like the answer to the test
is right at your feet and you still
[ __ ] it up
so um
i did i think six shows there
two in a strip of grass behind a [ __ ]
motel
where i was looking at a u-haul parked
and then to my right was a split entry
with a brand new roof and these just old
shutters on it
and then i was yeah then i was on some
sort of cow farm
hey do you know did you notice whenever
somebody calls for a fair catch like
you're supposed to give them a certain
amount of space
they never do it and they never call
that penalty i don't know why
um and now i'm down here in new jersey
uh i will tell you this man i fell in
love with connecticut
as far as i was i rented a house
in the middle of nowhere out in this
farm country and all that [ __ ]
and um had my family out there
my relatives everybody got tested came
down
saw my daughter and my new baby boy it
was awesome and
um i don't know oh man how good how good
does a new [ __ ] bronco look jesus
christ that's a good looking truck
um anyway um we were just in the middle
of [ __ ] nowhere
and i don't know i was just like i could
[ __ ] it and i say that a lot like i
could live here like i could legit live
there
um i don't know what the travel
situation was
guess i could have flown out of [ __ ]
hartford or some [ __ ]
but um as far as like
i've just been living in cities for so
goddamn long
um and even when i lived in the suburbs
when i was a kid
you know we didn't have the kind of
space that they had out there because it
was pretty much just like
farmland and what i loved i was like man
i could
live here and the only reason why i
would need a drum room
is because a soundproof room is just
because of the people i live with not
want to listen to me banging on the
[ __ ] drums
but like if i was by myself this is so
secluded i could just [ __ ]
i could just put him have him in my
living room
[Laughter]
and um i always feel like as much as i
love la and i do love la the thing
about i just always feel like when i'm
outside everyone my neighbors can hear
my conversation it's just everybody's on
top of each other
you know you pay for it when you live in
the city
all of those great restaurants all of
those bands that are now going to come
through anything that you're into
sports teams anything you want to do you
can do there but the price that you pay
is you don't have any sort of um
privacy um and [ __ ] is
cost a zillion dollars and and like
you know some of these [ __ ] homes i'm
just looking like
the home we rented i think was up for
sale
and um you know just the property that
it was on
and how big it was
the seclusion of it i mean i don't know
if you could even find that
in la like i don't know you're talking
like
eight figures and this thing was a
reasonably
wasn't cheap but it was reasonable so
[Music]
but the thing is i feel like i could go
out there and be happy
but then like i also get to leave
and go on the road and then you know get
to do shows in chicago and
l.a and all these cool [ __ ] cities
and
what would my family be going [ __ ]
crazy in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
um so you know i don't know
i don't know but i will tell you that i
oh my god i [ __ ] loved it
i really really loved it uh i would
probably go nuts after a while
because i don't know what what would my
act become
because so much my act is just
interacting with people and saying
something stupid or they say something
stupid and out there it's just like
nobody
i would start doing [ __ ] jokes about
the voice in my head
um but anyway um and then last night
we did we did one night behind the motel
three nights the farm in morris
connecticut and then we were in
ridgefield
connecticut last night and we did two
shows under a tent
that was open on the side
and uh i had a [ __ ] great in like
this
ridgefield's just like i don't even i
don't even know i was like
this beautiful little town
the [ __ ] police station i was joking
it looked like an old church
you saw these police cars racing by and
i was like what did somebody tip over a
cow like what's going on
i mean i know they probably have some
sort of [ __ ] going on out there
but um my whole career like
connecticut was something i drove
through
on my way down to new york i mean i did
some stuff
up there but i did most of it most of
the things that i did were like in
hartford or new haven
you know stuff like that so to me when i
picture
connecticut i picture the 84 whatever
the hell it is
or being on uh
95 driving up to boston i'd never gotten
off
and ventured you know five 10 miles away
from the highway it is like [ __ ]
beautiful beautiful beautiful state
[ __ ] god's country and they were
wearing mass up there and now i'm down
here near the jersey shura
and this seems to be predominantly no
mask
so we all have to be careful here
because people are choosing to think
that
it's not a big deal or it's over or
whatever
[ __ ] thing that they're doing i don't
know i don't even i don't even give a
[ __ ] anymore
i literally think that everybody in the
world right now
at least in this country is just acting
on information that they looked up
so there is no
like mainstream news anymore there isn't
there's nothing
there's nothing and what it is is you
is you have the internet that has all
the answers but most of them are wrong
right
like trying to find the right answer
like i i learned that you know when i
was trying to learn how to eat well
and trying to find
the right answers it's just like the
people who are lying to you
and putting sugar and all this [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ]
i mean the fact that these [ __ ]
people that feed
their own countrymen
pay lobbyists to go there so they don't
actually have to tell you what the [ __ ]
they're putting in the food
because people are now starting to get
educated about what it's doing to their
bodies
and maybe even causing cancers and [ __ ]
the fact that like
you have a better chance as a comedian
doing a [ __ ] joke of getting in
trouble in these [ __ ] [ __ ]
so try just trying to find out the
answers that way about nutrition
and then you you add it to the fact that
like you now have like morons
you know do you remember back in the day
the the card catalog
in the uh the library you go into the
library when i was a kid that's where
all the answers were it was in the
library
unless you had a little bit of money and
you bought a set of encyclopedias or
some [ __ ] right
you go to the library right and all the
answers
to the questions that you had were in
there okay but you had to know how to
use the card catalog
so if you were a [ __ ] you couldn't get
to the answers like me i could never get
to the end i'd have to try and find a
librarian to help me out
i could never figure out the dewey
decimal system
it took me forever to [ __ ] read
i i wasn't worthy of an answer i was too
stupid
but what the internet did was it got rid
of all of that
and not only does it now allow a dummy
like me
to be able to just ask a question and
get an answer
it also allows dumb people to provide
other answers that are incorrect which
is how we
somehow went from thinking the world was
flat to then understanding it was round
to now a certain segment thinking that
it's flat again
these are the people who back in the day
they wouldn't go to the library because
they'd be like me and they'd go to the
card catalog and they couldn't figure it
out
and they'd be frustrated and that would
be it and then they would leave
but now they can go on the internet
as i always say they go to amrite.com it
backs up everything that they're
thinking
and then they can get in chat rooms and
find other like-minded dopes
they can all agree upon it and then it
becomes a movement
you remember that guy i was talking
about a little while ago
he died he had an experimental aircraft
that he that he made and he went up he
shot a rocket he shot himself up in it
and when it came back down
unfortunately the parachute didn't come
out and the guy died
and everyone initially was laughing and
i'm thinking he was a flat earther but
from what i read now this might not even
be true but from what i read
he was just pretending to be a flat
earther so he could get their money so
he could build his [ __ ] rocket
and try it out i mean it is just a
uh it is a [ __ ] crazy goddamn
time i don't even know i don't know
what's going on but i feel like i'm
navigating it
in a much more intelligent way as a
[ __ ] i am
because now i just
i'm trying i don't engage with people
it's like when i was out doing that
chappelle gig and i ran to that guy in
yellow springs and he wasn't wearing a
mask and i said you guys don't wear
masks out here
and he's like no i don't i go oh you
know i choose to listen to the cdc and
then he goes well you know i could find
you just as much scientific information
information from scientists that say
it's actually not healthy to wear a mask
or whatever it's not doing anything to
wear a mask
and i just said hey a great to disagree
what am i going to do am i trying to win
this [ __ ] argument outside goddamn
you know laundromat don't wear a mask
i'm going to wear my ass and i'm going
to [ __ ] stay away from you and then
you can continue to [ __ ] do whatever
you're doing the cowboys with a big
completion dak prescott
um so oh by the way
i was watching the nfl network right
when the [ __ ] did they start with this
explosive play thing why do they always
do that [ __ ] you know it's it's just
football just stick with what the [ __ ]
we're talking about
and i was joking about that the other
night on stage remember for a while
there where they were just
all of a sudden for a few seasons
offsides became encroachment
um it's like stop trying to sound smart
okay
you don't have to make this some mit
[ __ ] or trying to overhype [ __ ] that
we've already seen
an explosive play you mean a big gain
you know this this this team gives up uh
a lot of big games and then
i don't think that's switching up being
like uh well this team has more
explosive plays
than the other team okay right off the
bat that's just this dumb stat
if you're just gonna if you're just
gonna have that stat by itself and
you're not gonna look at their schedule
and see who they played
it'd be like this team comes back a lot
and yet they play the falcons twice a
year
sorry atlanta yeah you got to look at
the goddamn schedule
touchdown cowboys
it was 30 to 15. let's see if they can
[ __ ] not have an extra point blocked
here
um anyway but i haven't
been having a great time up here doing
these shows i want to thank everybody
all the [ __ ] hardcore fans
that went out got their temperature
taken put a mask on did everything you
had to do
um we had safe shows hopefully and i
want to thank all you guys for coming
out i had so much damn fun
um shaking the rust off and becoming a
goddamn comedian again
it was it was uh it's been a great thing
so i got three days here in jersey
and then the tour is over um
you know and it's also been fun to do
the road and bring my whole family with
me
my son's doing great he can now turn
over anytime he wants to
and now what i do is i just
stick something in front of him that's a
little bit out of his reach and he's
making all these noises it's funny he
flattens himself
out he's trying to figure out how to get
over to the thing
and uh but now he's he's kind of come up
on his knees and he's he's starting to
do that thing you know they just rock
back and forth
they don't understand why they're not
making any head wave
it's adorable but um
and then my daughter loves him to death
and he's totally fascinated with her so
i'm kind of living the perfect life
right now
so all i need is these scientists who i
believe in
um to come up with some sort of vaccine
that other people have the balls to take
that burns this thing out
that's what i'm hoping sorry try to yawn
off mike
um hey what is are there any suggestions
for the uh washington the former
formerly known as the redskins um
washington redskins
new name let's see what's it gonna be
uh confirm the new name i was just
joking with keith robinson you know
[ __ ] trash in dc
you're like all right what would you the
washington d.c profilers
the marion barry's washington nfl's team
has confirmed that they will call
themselves washington football team
effective immediately
the name is not a final blah blah blah
native of groups native american groups
what was the new name all right i gotta
have suggestions here
red redskins
new name list all right what are they
going with
a comprehensive list of potential new
[ __ ] names let's see here
starting fresh the red hawks
well is that a real bird unlike the
[ __ ]
seahawks that's so funny bar stool
sports was talking about
last week how the seahawks is it's not a
real thing evidently
i think that's what they were doing i
don't know i watched so much [ __ ] i
believe it that came from them
for years i've been looking it up trying
to find out what a [ __ ] seahawk was
and i couldn't find one i went on
youtube and i did the usual seahawk
verse and they would just come up with
the football team i was like you know
seahawk versus fish
chicken hawk rhode island red all right
the red tails they're gonna try to stick
with red
now the red tail zone with an airplane
that's not bad the red hogs
ah it's a little bit like arkansas the
red wolves
this can't be right that is a native
american
with the [ __ ] wolf on his own head
the pigskins
the war soldier theme warrior
the generals the renegades
these all sound like the [ __ ] usfl
the braves
the federals the washington federals
used to be a usfl team how about the
federal reserves
no um
the griffins not so serious suggestion
all right i'm done
all that's all i think that was done i
think that whole website was a joke i
have no idea what they're going to
[ __ ] call him
i'm trying to think of what makes
washington d.c
unique you know like what are they known
for but you don't want to do that like
the boston clam chowder um
do you realize how many times i've had
clam chowder in my life
maybe six i always thought it looked
like [ __ ]
somebody spit it up back into the bowl
and then when you had manhattan clam
chowder
you know and they put a little tomato
sauce in there then it looked like you
know some wall street guy under stress
[ __ ] it out his ass you got blood in
your stool buddy
i'm sorry but you know a friend of ours
made clam chowder this week
when i was up in connecticut it was
absolutely delicious but i was never
into it now i kind of love it
but i'm still a [ __ ] german irish guy
so what i do love about it is not the
clams
it's not the chowder it's the potato
that's in it look at russell wilson with
that stiff arm
still got the ball away
amazing oh it's 30 to 22. wait a minute
look at this they're within eight points
touchdown in a two-point conversion
the cowboys they got a new coach man
they got another guy who just looks like
you know the last time they had a coach
who looked like a coach i feel like
is bill parcells you know the last
couple of times
the last guy and now this new guy they
both look like they work for like a
[ __ ]
like apple or something you know now
that steve jobs has
uh gone on to the uh next operating
system
in the next life uh i'm gonna be the
person coming out here showing you the
next uh
the latest iphone
and this iphone is uh gonna be the
reason why your new your last iphone
will no longer work as well
and then eventually you'll sell them
back to us and then we'll take it out to
the philippines and uh we'll
resell them again that's what we're
gonna do
um all right let me read a little uh
let me read a little uh advertising here
everybody i gotta grow i don't know why
i just have this great feeling they're
gonna they're gonna cure this [ __ ]
covid soon they're gonna come up with
something
you know rapid testing something
i actually think that for once they're
actually gonna try to [ __ ] do the
right thing
i really believe that i think we're
gonna stop global warming
they know i just think we're going to do
it
i just keep saying that and it feels
good to say it because i have no power
in any of this
so i'm just thinking positively all
right butcher box everybody you know
when it comes to me
quality matters but there's no more to
it
but there's more to it than texture and
taste butcher box
is better for you better for the animal
better for the environment
uh my favorite cut of meat is their
heritage bread pork
i love it it's the best pork chop i
always tell you i i don't i like all of
them meat their chicken is delicious
the beef is delicious and i love that it
comes right to my door
not everyone has convenient access to
high quality meat that's what she said
luckily there's a butcher box butcher
box believes everyone deserves high
quality humanely sourced meat
one less trip to the grocery store and a
better more affordable selection too
it's the best meat shipped right to my
door which means one less trip to the
grocers you know i hate when hunters now
say that they harvested
an animal i harvested an animal just say
you [ __ ] killed it
quit giving to the vegetarians you
killed it you shot it in the [ __ ]
head
it's dead you're not so you eat it
that's that's what that's you know
that's how the world works
that's how jeffrey dahmer did it um it's
the best meat
shipped right to my door which means one
less trip to the grocers
all meat is free well how am i going to
meet a divorcee
um all meat is free of antibiotics
and added hormones each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat enough for 24
individual meals unless you're on my 600
pound life
then it's enough for an appetizer uh
packed fresh and shipped frozen and
vacuum sealed so it stays that way
options like a hundred percent grass-fed
and finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage pork
what happened to the breed bread
heritage pork
wild caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what they're gonna do
and sugar slash nitrate free bacon
it's the way meat should be this is
making me hungry right now
um butcher box is the most affordable
and convenient way to get healthy
humanely raised meat i mean
we've said this we've said this a
thousand times the people are salivating
they want to know how to get it
um you're going to get the highest
quality meat for six bucks a meal they
have free shipping nationwide except
alaskan hawaii
right now butcher box is offering new
members ground beef for life
that's two pounds of ground beef and
every box for life
for the life of their subscription just
go to butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com two pounds of
ground beef that's [ __ ]
that's eight quarter pounders with
cheese baby
um all right my bookie-yay i don't [ __ ]
you doing all right
um i love mondays and sundays you know
why
two words nfl action and i got to do my
podcast
uh i love sundays almost as much as
brady used to love sundays in new
england ah
my bookies shots fired back at this [ __ ]
oh they're trashing me here but now he's
in tampa where the only thing he's got
to be excited about is that florida
sunshine yeah no state taxes and the
fact that i think that they won again
today
uh i'll tell you what though my bookies
got this whole online betting thing
figured out you sign up you make a
deposit and they'll match you dollar for
dollar
so you get some extra cash to play with
plus they have all kinds of cash prizes
contests and free bets tuned in too this
is the [ __ ] right here as long as you
just gamble responsibly something you
can afford to lose you'll have a friggin
blast
tune in late didn't place your bet in on
time don't even sweat it
because they let you bet the game's live
so you can analyze the game and then
make your picks
i've never heard of that in my life it
used to be there was over
you know even with roulette after the
wheel starts slowing down the guy does
the little magic hand across the board
it's over
these guys these guys are crazy um my
bookie
you gotta check out the website because
they got a hundred
thousand dollar super con uh super
contest
that runs the entire nfl season sorry
let me shut my phone off
um runs the entire nfl season pick
five games against the spread each week
score the most points by the end of the
season and you'll walk away with 25
grand
25 000 bucks but that's not it every
four weeks the player with the top
scorer wins five grand
five g's everybody my bookie is giving
it away
if you trust your intuition you can make
a ton of money and have a lot of fun
who could turn down money and fun uh
a religious person um sign up with
my bookie today and get your deposit
matched all the way up to a hundred
grand
well actually if you're if you're one of
the priests at mega church i don't think
you turn that down
i think you're making a ton of money and
you're banging some of the parishioners
but in your own way you're a rock star
right jesus christ superstar
uh it'll be easy the easiest money you
ever made in your life all you got to do
is claim the deposit bonus
and use the promo code burr it's not the
easiest money ever make any time you
gamble on the game you're losing your
[ __ ] mind and that's the fun of it
uh winning season is finally here and
it's only at my
bookie all right m-y-b-o-o-k-i-e
promo code bur b-u-r-r
all right let's get to the questions
here i'm trying to get to the questions
and get through this podcast before
the kiddos come back um
my uh oh my god my son had a blowout
today he was sitting on my lap
and he just he just kept going and going
and going and going and then i was just
like oh my god there's not a diaper in
the world that's going to be able to
hold that
you know i'm starting to learn starting
to learn as a dad you know
not standing there i used to be when you
know my daughter or
you know back in the day a relative's
baby i'd be holding them and they'd
start letting it go
you know i'd be standing there you know
like an idiot with the kids sitting on
my lap like you ever see those [ __ ]
morons who were down by the beach
when one of those uh tidal waves comes
in
is that what they call it what the [ __ ]
is a big wave it's a tidal wave
but there's the one that you know stills
like an earthquake under the water
and the wave is just coming and nobody
can see it coming what any way they call
it
it's not a tidal wave god damn it
it's not a typhoon is it a tidal wave
giant wave
name tidal wave a sunnah is a tsunami
what's the difference between a tidal
wave and a tsunami is a tidal wave like
it got to the afc championship game and
then lost but a tsunami's the super bowl
winner
versus tsunami
a tidal wave is by definition
waves caused by ocean tides where a
tsunami
is almost always caused by an earthquake
underwater
tsunami waves are also very different
from normal
wind-generated waves which many of us
have
observed on a local lake or a coastal
beach
that's [ __ ] fascinating
if this building shakes one more [ __ ]
i've been living in la for too long i
just keep thinking
that there's a earthquake this last
house we got here
all right tsunami waves are very
different
from tidal waves uh a tidal wave is by
death okay i already said that
tsunami waves are also very different
from normal wind gender waves
which many of us have observed on a
local lake or a coastal beach
observers of a tsunami will will
understand these waves are more like a
fast-moving
tide crashing into the shoreline yeah i
mean
those things are terrifying you don't
even see it coming and all of a sudden
just
rises up out of the water like a [ __ ]
cobra
normal ocean waves are caused by wind
weather tides and currents
where tsunamis are powered by geological
force tsunami waves are surface gravity
waves
that are formed as the displaced water
mass moves
under the influence of gravity and
radiate across the ocean like ripples on
a pond
yeah so it's in all all directions 360
degrees regular wind waves
only involve motion or upper mostly
i want to see what's the farthest a
tsunami can like
go and still like do damage
tsunami average
range in other places tsunamis have
known to surge vertically as high as 100
feet
30 meters most tsunamis caused the sea
to rise more than 10 feet
the indian ocean tsunami caused waves as
high as 30 feet in some places
according to news reports i mean that is
fascinating
all right how the [ __ ] did i start stop
talking about that
um all right i got questions here to
answer the lovely nia just popped in how
are you sweetheart how are you
how are ya i'm awesome
all right response to question about
scientists
getting [ __ ] every email from this
scientist said no
there are no science groupies scientists
don't get [ __ ]
this one is saying the opposite all
right so that's from andrew all right
physicist get [ __ ] hey bill new
listener here
in your september 14th monday morning
podcast you were speculating about
whether scientists have groupies or not
i laughed out yeah out loud because yes
they do
all right i want to know about this
world
and do the chicks that you get are they
like do they have like their hair up in
a ponytail
and they're wearing like black framed
glasses and then later on that night you
like
they let down the ponytail and you take
their glasses off and you do like a
makeover
and it's like wow wait a minute you're
actually the best looking girl at the
[ __ ] mall
sorry every coming to age movie was like
that and i was surprised to learn that
myself
i was i was surprised to learn that
i work at a university with a really
well listen if you're [ __ ]
teaching a class any dumb blonde's gonna
blow you to try to pass right
isn't that how it works nia bill
um i work at a university with a really
big
physicist depart physics department
sorry
you can tell i was not in that wing in
college
i don't even know if my college had a
science we didn't
we didn't have a science department uh
the place is populated with
greasy haired introverts who smile
smile spasmatically with half their
mouths and can only
maintain eye contact with you for
0.25 seconds per social encounter
there are some normal guys too there are
even a few slick
confident guys um all right so you got
the full range but most of them are sort
of introverted people
that feel more comfortable looking into
them uh down a microscope
into a microscope whatever you say
rather than looking at another person
over the last decade i've seen these
dudes have
crazy affairs oh wow divorce
and remarry have administrative meetings
called about them because of their
scandalous
behavior blah blah blah and the women
are hot
the only difference between the world of
sports and this one
is that women start with master's
degrees
wow yes bill i know what you're thinking
you don't this is i'm blown away
how hard are these physics groupies well
i'm an outsider to their world
the same way you are to the groupies
clamoring
to get to the the clippers players or
wherever the [ __ ]
i can objectively state that there are
many women who are hot
by any straight man's standards and
that's seen
in that scene sorry and they are all
intelligent and highly educated too
wow well yeah well i think if you're a
really smart chick how long could you be
around some [ __ ] [ __ ]
not saying that athletes are morons
there's another stereotype see people
were
breaking it down what's that i said 17
years apparently
seven we haven't been together for 17
years
16. 17 years i've been with you
um did dak prescott just throw another
[ __ ] touchdown
that gallop guy again there you go
ground can't cause a fumble he broke the
plane
no flags in the plague i love it
what are they looking at it over and
over and again to see if he uh
is that a touchdown yeah that's a that's
got to be a touchdown
all right sorry back to the uh scientist
[ __ ] here groupies
i guess the point is that if you excel
at anything there are women out there
who will notice
good genes right that's right yeah if
you're a hot chick what are you gonna
[ __ ] bang a loser
well my wife did oh
see i beat you to the punch and physics
beauty
physical beauty is just as important to
these guys as it is to any other
chump of course so the women courting
the top tier of scientists are hot
but to stick the landing they have to be
able to hold their own in a conversation
too so basically
it's another level uh i'm not in it
i'm good-looking and charming but i
don't have a shot well not with that
attitude
these women are interested in the
physics superstars nothing less
sincerely a nominee anonymous fellow
who please don't mention my name so i
don't lose my job thanks i never would i
would never mention a name
or something like that um okay first of
all that was all very educational and
second of all there's no reason why you
can't go out
and get the top level science scientist
groupie [ __ ] all right
you got to think more positive all right
maybe you got to have a little [ __ ]
end zone dance except a microscope dance
after you [ __ ] discover something i
don't know what it is
or just hang out with the physics
superstar
you know you'll get their runoff still
got to be like an eight right
it's not bad i don't know neil where
would you classify yourself as
like one through ten where would you put
yourself i mean to me you're a ten
you're a ten yeah well you know what now
you just became a nine to me
why you lose a point for arrogance for
confidence it's not arrogance it's
confidence
no it's arrogance
if it's arrogance or not who are you to
say that
i didn't say five you could you could
have been humbled and said
nine you know what the hell did i marry
you start talking about yourself in the
third point person
[Laughter]
[Music]
how awesome she is all right then she's
a 10 and she knows it
um all right if i was an insecure person
i would
have you stop listening to beyonce i
don't like what she's filling your head
up with
or does she even do that she just says
she's the [ __ ] right and then you guys
like yeah that's how i feel about myself
oh that reminds me last night i asked
people in the crowd if they felt they'd
ever accomplished anything great
and all i heard was women's voices going
yes yes so i said to this
woman in the crowd she was in her 20s
beautiful woman i said what are you
doing she goes i'm a head chef
and i was like all right i worked in a
restaurant too
you weren't a head chef though i know
but is that great
yeah that's great hey nia it's not going
to rain tomorrow isn't that great
it's that kind of great no that requires
skill you're talking about the weather
all right
wait a minute but wait a minute but
michael jordan's great
so if i became a head chef
i can be like hey michael jordan you
know as great as you are as a basketball
player
i'm also great who's comparing
themselves to michael jordan
well the way the question i was asking
that's like i
have like greatness
and she was a head chef somewhere and
she was saying that she was great
because of that
i agree with her
i disagree 100 percent why based on what
like based on michael jordan
based on the greatest chefs based on
that guy we saw based on that guy we saw
making the [ __ ] pasta
that's why people gotta stop saying
great they gotta stop saying they're
great because they're not
that's so stupid
do you know what's funny about that nia
is people give me [ __ ] because i say any
ways
instead of anyway that's dumb
it's ignorant correct to say any ways
instead
what are these anyway that people are
holding other people to
the standards standards of greatness
standards of using grammar correctly
does everything have to become dressed
down fridays
so everybody can feel like they're
included fine a head chef
and michael jordan they're both great
jesus christ all right let's just keep
going i give up you know i am officially
[ __ ] i don't
understand this i don't understand the
music i don't understand what's great
anymore
everybody's at 10.
i don't think i think i'm i'm definitely
old not cranky i'm honest
well i don't know why you can't give
someone their kudos because they became
head chef in the restaurant
i think that's amazing
no i mean because if you listen if you
were listening to the [ __ ] bit
it was sort of a joke question like have
you done anything great in your life
okay i don't want to do the [ __ ] bit
cause i need all the material i have
okay
and just [ __ ] becoming a head chef
you know yeah
yeah it's just like i mean yeah
i i've done some things in comedy but
richard pryor
is great people say that you're one of
the greats
i know the people on the internet and
everybody has a [ __ ] opinion
but i'm just saying there's richard
pryor and this [ __ ] everybody else
but there's a bunch of people out there
there's middle axe ah i give up i give
up you know what everybody's great
everybody's beautiful everybody's
beautiful
like that skinny [ __ ] used to say
who was beautiful and everyone wanted to
what the i don't understand her she's
one of the hottest chicks out there at
the time and she writes that [ __ ]
song
and everybody's like that's like a
[ __ ] you are beautiful
everybody wants to [ __ ] you
was she really no because she was down
on lot of [ __ ] at that time so
i think it was her no i am i am
well that's because she went from a teen
idol to rolling around the mud with a
hoo-ha hanging out she brought it on
herself
that's what she was doing when she
wanted to be dirty right
she became a blue comic i i know it she
can do a show with me anytime i don't
give a [ __ ] what she says
all right dishwasher rant
i love wash i love when people that
reminds me of my grandmother she used to
say wash
um hey old billy no beer gut
man it's all pizza and [ __ ] m m's uh
used to be booze
i wanted to talk about your recent rant
on the mm podcast that dishwashers are a
fraud
and don't work let me start by saying
this is true
and not true depending on the washer all
right educate me
because my experience with dishwashers
are
the only way they wash the dishes is if
there's a very
low fresh level of filth on them
like spaghetti sauce on a plate that's
been sitting there for longer than 20
minutes is too much to ask
for most dishwashers um
the only reason i know this is because
i've worked for an appliance
manufacturer for a few years oh i love
this person
he's he's going to give me the michael
jordan he's actually going to tell me or
she's going to tell me
the actual great one i look at 14 he's
going to look for a flag right
[ __ ] pushing off 27 you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right the only reason why i know
this is because i've worked for
um appliance manufacturer for a few
years i'm an industrial designer
a cool profession yes it is look it up i
i mean if you're doing something
industrial and you're designing it to
make it look nicer i just i think that i
think that's great
and can tell you that we basically
design the functionality within
dishwashers
as well as their appearance uh we are
not
engineers i repeat not engineers so in a
way
we are [ __ ] artists that also that
pitch
functionality based on a hunch that
certain parts we design
should do certain things and with all
professions
some of us are incredibly smart and some
of and some are not
in my opinion these there are certain
brands that you can tell
um have a better engineer engineer slash
designer work relationship
well yeah i think i understand what
you're saying it's like
you want us you want a car certain cars
look better than other cars
certain refrigerators are a little more
sexier than other is that what you do
are you the one that put the curves
in a [ __ ] vitamixer um if you and e
are looking to replace your dishwasher i
highly recommend
staying away from brands like whirlpool
lg and maytag
what about the maytag repairman he was
so lonely
uh i'm not even going to endorse my
company because i haven't had enough
time to make a decision on our products
but i hope this helps and confirms
you are kind of correct well could you
could you let me which which is which is
the dishwasher that works
because i could google right now best
dishwashers and all those other brands
you just named are gonna have such a
presence
because they have money to hire the top
nerds to make sure that they're on the
first page one of the first two or three
clicks
am i wrong about that i don't know um
all right
nia how do you present pronounce
f-a-u-c-i
i was gonna say fosse who's dr fauci i
know that name
that's not the supreme court person who
just died
ah fauci you gotta stay in shape with a
last name like that you can't be fat
fouchy
oh fat fouch eating all the fettuccine
fettuccine fauci
oh clam sauce himself it's his first
name alfredo
alfredo fauci all right uh hey bill i
wear a mask so don't yell at me
uh i'm i'm like the guy who wrote in
last week i really have a hard time
believing there is no
[ __ ] when there's video of fouchy
saying where i'm wearing a mask doesn't
work it's silly
uh well i think it also depends on when
these people say this [ __ ] i don't know
it seems like they were like
at first we weren't supposed to wear
masks everybody had gloves on i remember
that
um some will say that he said that to
make sure that
the n95 masks that were needed for
medical professionals wouldn't be
hoarded what a bunch of [ __ ] that sounds
like a bunch of [ __ ] to me
i have no idea where to get those nor
does the average american they don't
sell them at walmart
7-eleven or street vendors also don't
you think
uh they'd be less there'd be less
crowding in hospitals
if everyone was at least wearing a
bandana in february
which would produce less crowding and
need for an n95 mask
uh if you do believe that fauci i don't
even know who he is
okay i just saw a thing at one point
saying that the cdc said to wear a mask
so i'm i i believe in it
i'm not saying i'm right but i i i just
look at it like this way
mass verse no mask if i'm wrong all you
did was smell your own breath for a few
months right
uh if you're wrong then this [ __ ]
thing continues and more people lose
their small businesses and i don't think
anybody knows what the right answer is
so
i'm just airing on the side of caution
flying helicopters you don't have to go
out and do auto rotations
once you get your private license you
can fly for the rest of your [ __ ]
life and never do one
and just bank on the fact that your
engine's never gonna fail
you know you can you can you can't do
that and you can get away with doing
that who knows
you know it's not how i live my life
um anyway if you do believe that fauci
said this to prevent a shortage of mass
and it was the right decision then you
ex have to accept the fact that fauci
lied to the public knowingly
i don't know anything about this but i
agree with how you're analyzing this
information
how many liars do you know that only lie
once
well there's different types of liars
everybody lies
honey do you like this dress yes because
it gets me out of the store quicker just
[ __ ] buy it and let's get out of here
do i like it no i don't like it i don't
like spending the money either but i
know arguing with you is not going to
prevent you from buying it so yes i like
it you look great you look hot let's get
the [ __ ] out of here
um there's those kinds of lies and then
there's
uh smoking doesn't cause cancer lies
so all depends but everybody lies their
[ __ ] balls off
including jesus christ because he got to
hook her and there's no way he brought
up you know
if she said are you aren't you the son
of god
what nah i didn't know no what's what's
going on
i figured we could bang out here over
the water
well how are we gonna how are we gonna
[ __ ] in the what no we'll be on top of
it
okay if 40 000 people die for every one
percent
increase of unemployment give or take
ten thousand depending on the study you
read
how come no one is shouting you're
killing people of all ages across the
country
uh the way you yell you're killing
people's grandparents
um well because i think if everybody
just stopped wearing masks
and that's the wrong answer then that
ratio
is not going to remain a constant right
if if i'm understanding what you're
saying here
uh unemployment will kill conservatively
five thousand
five hundred thousand people um
all right well where did you get that so
i'm not supposed to believe fauci he's a
[ __ ] liar but i'm supposed to believe
you
who is not in the business of stopping a
pandemic
this is the whole thing about this and
my whole thing is i listen to people
with [ __ ] like this you know what i mean
i mean listen i'll listen to a sports
fan when he thinks about who's gonna win
a game it's just a [ __ ] game but a
pandemic
i'm not listening to regular people and
all i've been saying this is just
listen to the people that do this for a
living to try and stop this [ __ ] to try
and warn people
that's all i've been saying i don't even
listen to politicians
all right i don't listen to old joe or
crazy donny i don't listen to either one
of these this is these
these are our [ __ ] choices
old joe old joe biden and crazy
[ __ ] donald trump two of the two of
the oldest [ __ ] mother
they both look like they used to [ __ ]
host game shows
yeah older crazy neither one of them has
all their marbles why don't you [ __ ]
elect both of them and then they can
[ __ ] ah what do you think
um all right influencer
influenza is different than the flu um
there are many different influenza
strands that go unidentified each year
there was never mass testing of these
deaths to determine
that perhaps half of the deaths were of
the same strand
strain no it said strand you're wrong oh
strain okay
all right nia saying you're wrong this
would
allow it to be named and branded as
something that could more easily be
feared
um all right and although this is making
sense to me it's not that covet is a
conspiracy it's that it's
being reported irresponsibly according
to you
by the way what is your background
what is your background that's my thing
because if you're just a person who's
just going on the internet and they're
looking at clips of fouchy
and then you're looking up numbers and
then oh what about influenza
how many people does this and this is
how you're putting together your [ __ ]
term paper
um there's no way to know
where you got your information from
there's so many websites that are
pretending to be official that aren't
official
um i don't know i don't know the deal
that was what was great about the
library you had fiction in the
non-fiction
section where the internet everybody is
saying that they're non-fiction
um all right i can continue to read this
but like at the end of the day this is
just some [ __ ] guy
or woman just writing this in so uh
all right if it was and i used to feel
like this type of [ __ ] but i mean
i but i to go along with this that this
is like
that the smartest people in the world
the people that are our scientists and
the people that are running the
countries around the [ __ ] world
that they're all somehow missing the
boat
but you who do not have that position
you somehow
know what's really going on
and everybody has lost a bunch of
[ __ ] money
off of this thing so everybody is
[ __ ] losing
unless you can tell me there's this
secret economy
and they're trying to bankrupt all of us
then they're gonna come in and buy
everything and then i don't mean i don't
know
anyway and plus how hard is it to wear a
[ __ ] mask
everybody's being the biggest [ __ ]
baby it's like they're telling you to do
[ __ ] 500
squats every day just saying to put on a
mask
and the way that we eat drink smoke [ __ ]
none of it's healthy our [ __ ]
water is so goddamn polluted you gotta
have bottled water
that sat in plastic containers for
sometimes years
don't [ __ ] talk to me about this i
think this really just comes down to
is this it's a new inconvenience that
people don't want to [ __ ] deal with
but i'll continue reading this
uh it was off the cuff so i won't hold
you over the fire
for your words um
um but wait a minute hold me over the
five words
why don't talk to me like you just
proved something
you're just a guy who went on the
internet who looked up some [ __ ] and i
don't even know where you got it you're
not citing any of your [ __ ] sources
you have one [ __ ] link here
i mean that goes to wikipedia
one of them's a wikipedia thing come on
man
i went on wikipedia one time and i just
wrote some horse [ __ ] on my [ __ ]
page to see how long it sat there it sat
there for like three days um
it was off the cuff so i won't hold you
over the fire for your words well
first of all stop talking to me like
that like you hold some sort of
authority over me
and i'm sitting here like i'm doing my
six-month review with you
but the sentiment was that people will
be able to open their businesses again
these businesses have thousands of
dollars in debt destroyed credit
and no end in sight not to mention they
were forced to close
their businesses indefinitely making it
almost impossible to plan ahead
a large wealth transfer that should have
gone to the next generation is now going
towards debt payments
and banks yes and who do you hold
responsible for that let me guess just
rich people what about all the [ __ ]
selfish [ __ ]
that didn't do what people were telling
them to do people in power were telling
them to do
and they immediately was saying that the
world is flat this is all a [ __ ]
conspiracy
you can't always blame the the one the
top one percent
all right we're all selfish [ __ ] just
some of us are smart enough
to learn how to build a global business
all right
there are so many factors that have
created a war
on many fronts um so and so put out a
video where he simply questioned
if mass work and standing six feet apart
works
why is everything still shut down
well because people aren't wearing the
masks
if people would play ball
i don't know anyway the protests caused
spikes in major cities where businesses
weren't allowed to open
also irresponsible leadership well right
there you just back down that thing you
just give this quote
where you say well if it works then why
isn't shut down well protesters weren't
wearing masks
regular people are wearing masks people
a few blocks over on the beach here
are not wearing masks they're just not
wearing them
kids are having [ __ ] parties
that's why and then people catch it and
then they [ __ ] go to work i mean i
don't know what to tell you
also irresponsible leadership and
they're saying that standing six feet
apart
in mass is the best way to stop this
spread they're not saying it's a hundred
percent
guaranteed so when you combine that with
the fact that people are doing whatever
the [ __ ] it is they want to do evidently
then you're gonna bring them to work and
you know i feel that standing six feet
apart wearing a mask is probably the
safest thing you can do
but i don't want to do it standing
across from someone that went to a
[ __ ] rave
where no one was wearing a mask
you know this is just this [ __ ] thing
you can literally tell somebody that the
sky is [ __ ] blue
and somebody is just going to argue the
other side because they just don't want
to [ __ ]
they just don't want to hear somebody
telling them what to do um
and i am the king of that i am the king
of not
wanting people telling me what the [ __ ]
to do and i am for once just trying to
listen to what people in power are
telling me to do
because um i've been on social media and
i think people are out of their minds
that's just my opinion
um also irresponsible leadership
um let them protest and let them
and let them open where yeah
that's yeah they opened up states
earlier every [ __ ] state that opened
early then they then had a spike
we're at a point where we were expected
to deny logic and fall in line with one
of two
major opinions uh well they also
politicized it cnn and fox politicized
the thing it's i mean it's a [ __ ] show
so and i'll tell you or ma'am i'm not
gonna [ __ ] argue with you
if you think i'm full of [ __ ] and that i
that listening to scientists rather than
politicians
or news media outlets and all that type
of [ __ ] is stupid then you know
do it do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do i i don't i
i don't give a [ __ ] whatever i i don't
care don't wear a mask i don't give a
[ __ ] go out there go breathe on people
go lick a [ __ ] pole i don't care
um all right black voter dear bill amber
i am a black voter
uh that's gonna be a new next netflix
series black voter
um legitimate question for you this
morning can you please explain to me why
liberals like yourself cannot deem joe
biden a racist
as succinctly as you do donald trump all
right i'm not reading the rest of this
okay i'm just not reading this first of
all i'm not a joe biden guy
uh second of all uh how do i know you're
black how do i know you vote how do i
know
who you are um
i don't know i i just i don't know but
send me
sen person okay something like this
i'm not [ __ ] reading this just
send a video read this question
all right read this [ __ ] question all
right
read it word for [ __ ] word like it is
here so i know it's you and then i will
read this thing all day
but i am not getting involved in this
politics [ __ ]
where someone's saying like obama's the
worst president ever
and i'm a democrat or donald trump he's
just a [ __ ] murderer and i'm a
republican like you know
that stupid gaslighting [ __ ]
horseshit i'm not reading that [ __ ]
all right um i [ __ ] hate joe biden i
[ __ ] hate donald trump i hate that
these two old [ __ ] [ __ ]
are my only two choices okay i hate it
all right i like bernie sanders
that's who i liked i think a lot of
people on the left like bernie sanders
and the democrats will not give him to
me or anybody else
because they want a company man in there
that's going to protect the oil
companies and keep the wars going
and that's why everybody republicans and
democrats
don't like [ __ ] donald trump because
he's a [ __ ] wild card
and they don't know what he's going to
do which is what was the appealing thing
about the guy
all right but now that he's been there i
don't know i compare him to like jeff
george he has an amazing arm but he's a
[ __ ] locker room cancer
um all right black voter
all right that was actually insulting to
jeff george because he had a better arm
than [ __ ]
this guy makes a speech just my opinion
all right black voter i
already did this one okay lady lady
listener
all right dr dre's divorce
now do i need you to send in a video
um lady listener here did you see that
rapper
and producer dr dre is getting divorced
from his wife of around 20 years yes i
heard about this
in california no fault state it's going
to cost some money
this past week she filed saying she owns
his name
and half of his hit uh his hit album
chronic 2000 which he produced and
wrapped on around the time they were
married
well that's probably how it's going to
go down in court owns his name
i don't know about his name now
newspapers
and online sources are spinning it as if
it's okay that this man's career that
started in the 80s
should be split completely in half she
wants to own
half of his identity that he already had
also two weeks ago she filed asking for
two million dollars a month in spousal
support
all of his children two with his current
wife three with previous wife
are adults so no child support we'd love
to hear your thoughts
link posted below um
well first of all it's a negotiation
so my experience in business is that
the first ask is they ask for the entire
solar system
and if you're dumb enough to give it to
them
then you know you lose
so dr dre is not going to be dumb enough
to be like okay
to any of this [ __ ] so what she's asking
for
she she'll be happy if she gets if she
gets one third of what the [ __ ] she's
asking for
she'll be good so that that's how the
game is played
um there's no
divorce attorney that's gonna say that
what she's asking for
is a dumb strategy it's a great strategy
it's just it's a business thing you just
go in
and if the guy's worth a billion dollars
you you just say hey you know i
i feel like i'm worth 750
million of that billion dollars and then
he's like oh what the [ __ ] blah blah but
then they're going to settle out of
court for 200 million she's still going
to get 200 million
so um i don't know
i don't know i don't know what to tell
you but i'm i've left all of that [ __ ]
behind
as far as just
trashing you know
women and all that [ __ ] crap you know
what the [ __ ] it is that they do
they know what the [ __ ] it is that we do
so you got to have your head on a
[ __ ] swivel
and that's the deal and when it comes to
when you're getting divorced you have a
bunch of money
the person with less money is always
going to ask for a [ __ ] zillion
dollars because i know a couple of
[ __ ]
females in this business whose husbands
weren't making any money and guess what
the [ __ ] they did they asked
for a lot they asked for [ __ ] spousal
support
i can't i can't even say without
laughing
all right i'll tell you right now
i got too much [ __ ] pride
i got too much [ __ ] pride to [ __ ]
ever ever have another adult
pay for my uh my life but you know
unfortunately the way things are set up
you know there's a lot of women who are
institutionalized as much as they're
walking around talking [ __ ] that they're
warriors and they're brave and they're
living their best
life at the end of the day you know they
don't have any problem doing [ __ ] like
this
taking the [ __ ] easy way out so i
mean uh good luck to dr dre i mean i
think
look whatever she asks for he can afford
to give her and he's still gonna be
living a great life
and uh it's oh it's been ridiculous male
or female
when [ __ ] like this goes down
all right but i don't know as things get
more progressive and fair
i think that you're going to see more
guys doing this which is great for guys
because if guys start doing it then the
law will be changed
because it's affecting women
[Laughter]
all right that's my last ignorant thing
hey wear a mask don't wear a mask all
right vote for trump vote for biden i
don't give a [ __ ]
all right i'm just trying to tell jokes
here i don't want to be political or
whatever and you guys are not going to
convince me
to not wear a [ __ ] mask and i'm not
going to convince you to wear a mask so
let's just agree to disagree
and let's just get back to being [ __ ]
silly again all right go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll check in on you on thursday